so I might not be doing daily wine
videos anymore but I haven't retired
from throwing my two cents into the ring
because let's be honest I'd just like to
hear myself talk
GameStop has caused a lot of noise and
as a former retailer now to the scale of
gal you know gamestop but with one store
unit and thinking like a retailer pretty
much my whole life and writing a book
called the Thank You economy and
thinking about the end user
there is a crapload of dynamics in this
gamestop story if you don't know what's
going on I'll link some stuff up to give
you the original stories the story is
Game Stop retailer 1,400 or 4,000 not
sure how many units out there tons of
stores in the u.s. major retailer of
gaming went with a new game that came
out for PC open them and took out all
the coupons for this game and it's
called no the PC I'll do a game that has
a lot of hype anybody was waiting for it
they shipped the PC game and inside
there was a coupon code for that game
for free on an online service called on
live now everybody's killing game stuff
right how can you do this how can you
open packages and take something out
from a sealed package that was intended
for the user sounds ridiculous doesn't
sound like thank you economy
sounds like screw you economy but that's
not the case when we really pay
attention to what's going on here
because Game Stop had no idea that that
coupon to us in there and they have a
competitive service coming out
eventually you know go online download
it to get the play and buy it if you
want so from their standpoint this
partner this gaming partner didn't let
them know that this was going to be in
the package when they found out they
responded by telling their employees and
the managers across wall stores to go
ahead and take it out fine a lot of
different things I want to touch on here
number one GameStop was concerned
giving any leg up to an live.com in this
battle which is clearly the future
because their online stores aren't and I
respect their business decision because
it's right right you don't want that we
weren't aware of it
it's your source you have the
entitlement to decide what you want and
that gaming partner should have done the
right thing by you and allowed you to
know that was coming and clearly that's
where it's going to end up but too many
businesses today when thinking about
keeping or winning the consumer don't
think about the consumer in their
actions an attempt to hold off on
live.com
GameStop hurt their own consumers we're
just saying I think about all the time
there's two ways to build the biggest
building in town one just build it to
tear down the other buildings around you
I believe in the Thank You economy in a
world where I can do a flip cam video
right now and give on live.com a lot of
exposure in a rubber or tweeting and
twittering instagramming and recording
you've got to do the right thing because
the wrong thing is always wrong there's
a great article written by one up calm
about the original article about the
original instance and it's fascinating
they said in it and I just was blown
away by this you know they got the whole
story and they said something like
gamestop clearly didn't want to give
online any additional exposure in
addition to what may end up being from
this two year ahead start on life is
good ahead of them and if you want to
give them any additional exposure by
doing the wrong thing for the end
consumer even though it might have been
the right business principle they've
just gone on and given on live.com and
noxious amount of exposure I'm sure all
the gamers out there are aware of the
brand but for casual guys like me that
I've never thought about it don't really
play it often not in their inner circle
online.com has just built
and by accident business I'm gonna hear
somebody talking about it might say you
don't want check out on live.com these
are the fascinating things you might be
right but doing anything that's wrong
for the end-user is always wrong